and the 10th of August 1976 one of my
youngest sisters and went walking with
four of her children and there was a
clash between an active service unit of
the Irish Republican Army and the
British Army and the British Army shot
the IRA man driving car through the head
and his car went up onto a footpath and
append my sister an and three of her
four children against the railings and
all the children were killed and Andrey
was only six weeks old John was doing
half and Jovan was only it and the young
IRA man Danny lemon was also dead so my
sister was dangerously ill at that time
and not expected to live so um I
some of us got together and we said this
has got to stop we've got to solve our
problems another way because violence
doesn't work and myself
I'm Betty Williams whom I met the day
the three children were buried and
Kieren look young a young journalist at
the time three of us joined together to
start what became known as the peace
people and it was it was grassroots
spontaneous movement saying you know we
have got to use different ways to solve
our problems that was the beginning of
peace people
you